thank you uh yasser yes i'm here with
world number two fabiano caruana
after a uh tense yet peaceful
in the end game fabiano take us first of
all uh through the game
yeah i i think i probably surprised him
with my choice of opening
but you mean taking on c4 yeah
the qga is i mean it's also not the most
popular line there's 96 line although
it's pretty decent
um yeah this is uh this is a good move
um
did he surprise you with this move 95 i
knew it exists i i was kind of
hoping because i i i didn't know the
move too well
i mean there's usually people go for for
these positions i think
um but it's it's a bit better for it or
i guess i could
or i guess i could take on e5 but i
wasn't sure about this ending like take
knight d7 f4 b5 bishop e2 and then like
bishop b7 he'll play b3
to stop my the movement of my pawns i
thought at least and then
slowly bishop b2 a4 we were actually
looking at
something similar and in this position
not even play the move f4 but rather
sacrifice upon with the move bishop to
e2 yeah i don't know
three didn't think about this this was
actually almira's proposition
this uh very interesting bishop to e3
this looks kind of kind of bizarre to
just give up the pawn
but maybe yeah um
yeah i mean i i don't i don't know
exactly what's going on this position
but i
for some reason i thought queen c7 a bit
more direct a bit more forcing
um i mean he's sort of obligated if he
wants to fight for an advantage to go
for this
and i thought the position should be
okay
uh yeah it's it's very important that
queen of three have bishop b7 and i
equalize
and if he takes on f6 you take with the
pawn yeah i have to but this
i mean i actually don't think he wants
to go for because you're probably better
at this my my pawns yeah they're a bit
damaged but uh
i have the queenside majority which is
more important and i have a lot of
development
so so i think we played correctly
okay i wasn't entirely sure i mean this
is also is also possible but then after
a4 i'll probably have to play b4
and i didn't want to fix my structure
like this so i thought rook b8 is a bit
more flexible
yeah after the game he actually
mentioned a4 um
instead of e4 but i don't know exactly
what the difference is
compared to the game like either way i
take i think at some point he'll have to
play
e4 so i don't know have you considered i
think it was here that
almira proposed this idea with bishop to
d2
try to force you to play uh b4
yeah if i have to play b4 then this is a
great move um
yeah bishop d6 the problem is he gets
bishop c6 so i should probably
develop like this and put my queen
somewhere i guess here
uh yeah i mean these things actually he
doesn't really catch i was seeing like
similar resistance he doesn't catch the
rook but
i also don't really want to fly for an
f6
but it's like if i get bishop d castle
bishop d6 i do
extricate my rook definitely still
playable yeah it's
of course it's not a pleasant position i
mean obviously something didn't go
quite right but i mean e4 is also the i
think the most natural move maybe
not the most accurate but but the most
natural
um yeah so i like he thought for an
enormous amount of time here and i
probably
um started to like get a bit too clever
because at first i wanted to like
to take with the pawn naturally rook a7
bishop p6 which is i think a nice
nice tactical point is that if he goes
for this which looks like it wins a
piece i have rook d8 and
i end up up a pawn but but i saw this
move rook
rook a6 and i didn't see exactly how to
like
to free my pieces i thought rook da
queen h5 and
i was getting worried about this but now
i see the evaluation says i'm totally
fine so
my world mostly because of tactics right
c4 you take and then he cannot take on
b5 because of queen
yeah yeah maybe this is this is the
right way to have played uh because if
he plays like in the game i can
play rook v6 or or a number of moves and
i have just a much better version
compared to
to what i got which was rather
unpleasant i thought
i just i just missed bishop d2 when i
when i played rook b6
uh and i thought that if i
go for this like or or queen sticks back
he anyway plays bishop d2 and
this is quite unpleasant yeah so i i
thought okay
my position got sad but uh but it
it's not i guess so bad were you worried
at any point
yeah i mean i was a bit worried after
three um
but i decided just to like not try to
you don't get out of this tactically but
just try to systematically trade pieces
and
and hope that the drawing margin is
large enough um but yeah he
somewhere here like he shouldn't trade
on g6
because one of his main things is that
he has the
kingside majority which can actually
start moving so he should do
maybe something like he did in the game
or maybe queen h5 but something to try
to trade the bishops
and then play f45 and f5 and
after this there is really no more
this plan doesn't exist anymore because
i i control the f5 square
um and yeah
maybe it's still unpleasant but i was
happy when i
when i saw this because uh the drawing
margin suddenly becomes really huge like
any of these
i think this bishop before was a very
nice way to simplify the position
yeah i just i i don't really um like
i can maybe play something like this and
it might eventually be a draw but i i
still have some weak pawns and i really
want to get rid of his
uh his great bishop so i'd rather not
suffer and i thought okay this
this should uh clean the game up a good
result for you uh who do you have
tomorrow
i don't know and what is your strategy
with the white pieces are you going to
go
i think i might have a double black
actually i think so um
i need to check i don't know who i play
against but i think i have a double
black
okay well we're looking forward to see
you uh tomorrow thank you fabio thanks
guys back to you in this video
thank you christian thank you fabi